cubans take the streets in
anti-in massive anti-government protests
thousands of cubans took the streets
sunday in protests of the country's food
shortages and high prices
amid the chronovirus pandemic in the
anti-government protests in the capital
of havana lasted about two and a half
hours before it was broken up
when a few protesters toss cobblestones
at police leading to several arrests
we are fed up with the cues and
shortages that's why i'm here one
middle-aged protester said the communist
party is suffering from its worst
economic crisis in decades and has
recently seen a surge in corona viruses
cases coronavirus cases
cuba president miguel diaz-canel
undermines sunday's demonstrations while
visiting the small town of san antonio
de la
de los banos which has been plagued by
power shortages i'm going to continue
the next story is from the independent
cuba protests spread to miami as
president threatens battles in the
streets by the way i
landed in miami last night okay
when i was in uh what do you call it the
miami airport when this was happening
m.i.a
everybody traffic was the worst i've
ever seen
flags everywhere honking the horn you
see it all over the place right well the
miami airport is just outside of little
havana of course
45 minutes away yeah so thousands of
thousands of miami joined protests in
solidarity with the cuban people
rallying against the government
because of food and vaccines shortages
and rising prices cubans in the
thousands also protested on sunday
against the government of president
communist party we know that the country
is also struggling with the sanctions
imposed by the trump administration
after president barack obama tried to
normalize
relations with the country sunday's
protest was one the biggest
anti-government demonstrations in memory
the associated press rights and the last
story i'll write read is the following
cubans denounced misery in the biggest
protests in decades
the rallies widely viewed as astonishing
for a country that limits dissent
were set up by economic crisis etc okay
so here's
here's a new york times tweet can you
pull up the new york times tweet pull up
the new york times tweet which to me
it's
very very confused i don't know if you
saw this or not did you see the new york
times
no i'd like to see it here's a new york
times tweet here's a new york times
tweet tell me what you think about this
shouting freedom and other
anti-government slogans
let me read that to you again shouting
freedom
and other anti-government slogans
hundreds of cubans took the streets and
the cities around the country on sunday
to protest food and medicine shortages
and a remarkable eruption
of discontent not seen in nearly 30
years let me let proper english i'm
middle eastern
english is my fifth language so i took
efl not even esl because esl is second
language efl is fifth language right
okay never even heard of that
i haven't either shouting freedom
and other anti-government slogans yeah
does that
mean the word freedom is a form of an
anti-government slogan yes is that how
i'm reading it you're reading 100
english off no
that is correct so new york at this time
is saying freedom is an anti-government
that's what they're saying of course
that's what they're saying yes well the
other thing that they were shouting
for the roof they were saying liberta
libertad have you ever seen scarface
yeah that's what they're shouting and
the other the other thing they were
saying is
we are not afraid we are not afraid
freedom freedom freedom yeah yeah yeah
but what i'm saying
i'm saying yes the answer is yes now the
only thing open to us
the only thing open to interpretation is
are they referencing
cuba where it's a communist country and
freedom does mean anti-government or is
that the new york times philosophy in
general
because that is not an act every word is
thought out very very clearly through
there okay
but so on what's your point with that
pat i'm feeling
he's saying the new york times is saying
freedom is anti-government and that
they're going to transpose that same
thought process here
which is what essentially they're doing
yeah i mean new york times is saying
the word freedom is anti-government
anti-cuban government no
no no no anti-gun and other
anti-government slogans
the word freedom is an anti-government
slogan
since when has the word freedom been a
bad word to use
since when has that been like hey any of
these stuff like
today if you today watch this your
question for you if today
you see somebody with a truck with an
american flag on automatically are they
democrats or republicans
republican why why
they they're more patriotic but why
though
i'm confused of course i've asked myself
that same question why i get that
being democrat is somehow seen as less
patriotic
yeah but what i'm trying to tell you is
democrats are afraid to carry their
flags
because when you drive down like when
you drive down a house if you see an
american flag
most people are going to say that house
is what it's a republican house
why though why are republicans proud to
represent
democrats cannot represent their flag
because why why is that
why is it patriotic to say freedom is
good
why is it why is it such an offensive
word now there's a new york times has
got the kind of influence they got to
say hey
freedom is an anti-government slogan
what are you talking about
what are we talking about here i escaped
iran to be here
for what for freedom you know when i was
in germany at a refugee camp you know
who was there people from albania
people from yugoslavia yugoslavia
doesn't even exist today
yugoslavia poland czechoslovakia now
it's not even czechoslovakia
czechoslovakia all these other places
countries that were under soviet regime
yeah and we were all
there we all had one in common we were
begging
for freedom sure everybody was afraid to
claim their religion everybody was
afraid
to voice that everybody was afraid
everybody wanted this thing called
freedom
and today freedom is an anti-government
slogan wow
you know two weeks ago in the podcast we
were talking about um
cnn celebrating china's 100 year
anniversary of communism and
and this ties in with what i'm going to
ask you right now um
you look at cnn you look at the new york
times they're you know as donald trump
used to say they're failing right the
failing new york times but cnn's ratings
speak for themselves
you cannot have a 40 dip in your ratings
and not have some sort of economic
disaster with a company
they go hand in hand yeah so are they
being secretly funded
by china i mean is that where the
revenue gap is coming from cuba
no i'm talking about liberal media
outlets i'm just wondering is there a
responsibility cuba is foundational just
so you know cuba
is funded by china china has a chokehold
on cuba there is a
power of china coming in to use cuba as
a platform to
that that is already one of their chess
moves that fits their profile that's
exactly what they do
let me ask you because do you have two
instead of one i need two
i need somebody in their late 30s and
somebody in their 20s to give me two
perspectives
maybe maybe i'm just not understanding
this okay but in my opinion
and i could be wrong you're gonna
probably teach me something as someone
who basically had their freedom or
rights taken away in iran
shouting freedom liberta or against the
government in cuba
anti-government anti-communist you know
regimes yeah why is that a bad thing i
i'm not understanding the
like whether this was the new york times
new york post washington
what i'm what i'm not understanding that
why is it a bad thing yeah like shouting
freedom while you're under a communist
regime
i don't think it is what i'm saying is a
bad thing the fact that
new york times categorically puts the
word freedom as an
anti-government slogan anti-cuban
government it said
anti-government slogan but they're
talking about cuba it's not it's not
about but
what do you mean talking about cuba it's
a doesn't it tell stories about cuba
let me maybe i'm not understanding let
me ask you bring that tweet back up
are you sincerely telling me you don't
see
messaging in the title you don't see any
you don't read into it
that's why i asked the question right
for you to inform me well then i'm
thinking
shouting freedom and other government
slogans hundreds of cubans
took to the streets so i'm thinking this
is a cuban story i'm not reading into it
i get it this is america you know what
they could have done
they could have done they could have
done shouting many other things but
saying
freedom and other anti-government
slogans
other anti-government slogans what is
wrong with shouting freedom
nothing is nothing but new york times is
calling that an
anti-government slogan but it is an
anti-government slogan in cuba
you cannot it's okay so in new york
times let me ask you a question let me
ask you a question
is is new york times anti-government or
pro-government
i guess they're pro-government i guess
yes they're pro-government what do you
mean you guess they're pro-government
i don't i don't have like the strong
opinion on new york times i think this
is a story about cuba i'm not reading it
that's the problem with the fact that
you don't realize the power of
wordsmithing let me tell you there was a
movie called uh
flash of genius you ever seen a movie
flash of genius it's the story about the
intermittent uh what do you call it
windshield wiper the kid the guy that
invents the
intermittent windshield wiper if you've
never seen this you got to watch this
movie okay
he's invents it he goes presents us to
ford
ford steals it from him they say he
didn't come up with it we came up with
it
he shows it to chrysler 4 to everybody
they take it
he gets nothing for it he goes against
them
for years loses his marriage loses his
kids
loses everything eventually years later
he gets paid 28 million dollars
and everybody had to officially say that
this man invented invented the
intermittent windshield wiper he
represents himself because he has no
money he's so broke
and he gets up there and he says ford
says
to create the intermittent uh uh what do
you call it a windshield wiper
all you need is four pieces you need
this you need this you need that you
need this
meaning force trying to say it's not a
big deal he didn't invent anything
unique
he says you're right but i got a
question for you
um i'm gonna use a few words tell me if
you've ever used these words in your
vocabulary you ever used the word
success yes you ever use the word
hi yes you ever use the word happy you
ever use the word
the you ever use the word there like
yeah where you're going with this
he says how come you never wrote
a best-selling book just like he puts
the book up
which is the all-time best-selling book
of all time he sold you know hundreds of
millions of copies
how come you've never written the
best-selling book all the words in this
book
are words you know but the problem with
you is
you don't know how to put the words in
the right order to become a best-seller
the author here did what i did is i know
how to put
those four items together that anybody
could have done and i invented it i own
the rights to they need to pay up and
they need to tell because you've cost me
my marriage
my family my kids they need to say
publicly
there is power in word smithing
new york times has a lot of influence
and they know how to put words together
to manipulate the agenda they're trying
to impose
to the average american voter that
doesn't read into it and they say
freedom anti-government slogan and they
say yeah you know what freedom yeah
people who say freedom people who say
free the people who say freedom they're
probably republicans
no freedom is why america was is the
greatest nation on the planet today it
could still change
freedom is the reason why america is so
special freedom of speech freedom of
enterprise freedom of assembly freedom
of religion i can go on with all these
different freedoms that they provide you
but now it's an anti-government slogan
let me just say this as a writer uh that
is 100
part of the new york times messaging
that is what they do it's subtle
but it's consistent and it's constant
they use the word freedom
as an anti-government slo slogan if they
were doing what you think they were
doing
because it's a story of cuba they should
have said shouting freedom
and other phrases in cuba that might be
interpreted
as anti-government comma go on with it
but they didn't do that
so that's the exact i was like a 50
words rather than four words yeah but
there's no limit on tweet twitter now
um but anyway that's exactly what they
did they made that
they do it all the time so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]